- [Instructor] In previous
videos we have already defined
or provided a definition for energy
as the capacity to do work.
We have also talked about
the notion of a field.
We have talked about things
like an electric field
or a gravitational field.
And these are really mental constructs
that we have produced to
explain force at a distance.
For example, if I have a planet here
and then I have some other
object here that has some mass,
we know that these are going
to exert forces on each other,
and actually equal and
opposite forces on each other.
And scientists said, well,
they're not touching each other.
How are they exerting
forces on each other?
And so they introduced
this notion of a field
that each of these objects produce,
a gravitational field of sorts.
Now Einstein came later and said,
well, actually they're
warping space, time,
et cetera, et cetera.
But a field is one way to think
about how they're able to induce a force
so to speak in each other.
Similarly, if you have
two electric charges,
let's say you have two negative
point charges like that.
We know that they push away on each other,
that like charges repel.
Well, they're not touching each other.
How do they know to have
a force being applied
to them in opposite directions?
So once again, there's this idea
that each of these produces a field,
the other one is in the
other electric charges field.
And then that field
somehow applies that force
or makes that force
happen to the other thing.
Notice, the field is a useful concept
to predict what will happen
and to quantify how it could happen.
But it really is just something
in our minds to make
sense of the universe.
So with that out of the way,
let's look at this water
wheel right over here.
You can see that the
water comes down from here
and then it falls.
And as it falls, it pushes,
it fills up these things right over here
which then pushes it down.
And then the whole wheel turns.
And then that wheel could do work.
Actually could do useful work.
In a physics context, not all
work is necessarily useful.
But this could actually do useful work.
So what I wanna think about is
two different drops of water.
I have a drop of water here,
maybe the same drop of water.
When it's up here versus once
it has gone all the way down
and has been dumped into what I'm assuming
is a stream down here.
Now, which one has a
higher capacity to do work?
Pause this video and think about that.
Well, I just told you that
when the water drop is up here,
it has the capacity as it falls
because of the gravitational field,
which is pulling down on it.
And by the way, if the gravitational field
is pulling down on the water drop,
that water drop is also
pulling up on earth.
But this gravitational field of earth
is pulling down on that water drop.
And because of that,
if the water drop is not supported
it can actually do work in this example
on its way to being in this
position right over here.
Now this position right over here,
in theory, it could maybe still do work.
Maybe there's a cliff right over here
and it can continue to pour down.
But the water drop up here
clearly has the capacity
to do more work because
it has the potential work
that it can do from
going from here to here.
And then obviously it could then continue
to do any work that this
position would allow it to have.
So we would say that this water drop
by virtue of its position,
has a higher capacity to do
work and has more energy.
And what is a form of that energy?
Well, in this case, it's
gravitational potential energy.
It's energy that is stored.
And I put that in quotes
because it's not like
you're going to be able
to open that water drop and
all of a sudden see energy,
but it's energy that's stored
by virtue of its position.
Another way to think about it
is instead of imagining that the energy
is stored in the water drop,
and it is really happening in our minds,
is to say that that energy
is stored in the field.
In this case, this gravitational field.
Now the gravitational field
is pulling on this water drop.
So the direction of motion
would actually reduce
the energy in the field.
So if we just let things happen,
earth's gravitational field
is going to pull on this water drop.
And actually that water drop
has a gravitational field
that's going to pull up on earth,
but as that water drop gets pulled down,
the total amount of energy stored
in the field is going to go down.
Now what happened to that energy?
That energy gets
transferred out of the field
into kinetic energy of this wheel,
which could then be
transferred into other things.